hi everyone I'm at Indiana University in Bloomington Indiana
my alma mater
I previously posted a video about snipers on the roof of the school buildings
here at Indiana
um no snipers or police so far today
pretty peaceful Sunday on day 4 of the encampment
um when I saw videos and photos of my friends getting tackled and arrested
I knew I had to come down for the day
if you can hear the music in the background um
that would be Chabad House
uh they've been blasting 🇮🇱 music as well as very patriotic American music
as I posted on my story
um right across the street from the liberation encampment
I'll be trying to post more updates as they come
but yeah 55+ arrests so far this week
many students facing one year bans from campus as well as faculty
if you'd like to learn more and support
please follow @ psc_iu on Instagram and click their linktree